no
economía en france 24 con daniel
hablando las buenas noches daniela para
ustedes por angela buenas noches vamos a
comenzar hablando como ha sido los
últimos días de la guerra en ucrania los
envíos de gas natural a europa están en
vilo por el conflicto así es ángela pues
mire se estima que el 40 por ciento del
gas natural que consumen los países de
la unión europea proviene de rusia sin
embargo la crisis ha hecho que esos
envíos sean intermitentes en los últimos
días el gasoducto yamal es responsable
de al menos el 15 por ciento del gas que
llega al oeste de europa desde rusia el
jueves temprano su operadora había
informado que los flujos de envío habían
disminuido drásticamente en uno de sus
puestos de control por ejemplo
reportaron una caída desde 17 millones y
medio de kilovatios hora por hora a poco
menos de 600 mil el jueves pero en la
tarde ya se habían comenzado a
restablecer estos flujos el ministro de
energía de ucrania dijo lo contrario que
los suministros al bloque han aumentado
desde el inicio de la guerra e instó a
la unión europea a dejar de comprarle
gas a gas qué es la empresa más grande
de rusia esta misma compañía justamente
confirmó un aumento de la demanda del 5
por ciento en apenas una semana pues
occidente ha querido sancionar a rusia
por todos los frentes - por el
energético pues estaría en juego el
suministro ruso del que dependen tantos
países de esa región y de ahí la
pregunta constante que nos hemos hecho
que puede hacer europa para dejar de
depender del gas y del petróleo rusos
pues la presidenta de la comisión
europea úrsula von der leyen volvió a
hacer énfasis en la necesidad que han
expresado varios líderes occidentales y
es acelerar la búsqueda de fuentes
alternativas de energía para reducir la
dependencia del suministro energético de
rusia escuchamos lo que yo
james jones estamos preparando en caso
de represalias en particular estamos
trabajando para diversificar nuestros
suministros de energía de hecho estamos
aumentando nuestros suministros de gas
natural licuado para asegurarnos de
tener suficiente energía durante esta
temporada y estamos duplicando las
energías renovables que son la solución
más inteligente y limpia para crear
independencia de las fuentes de energías
rusas formulación y de todas maneras
estas son medidas a mediano y largo
plazo y no a corto plazo y de hecho
estados unidos ha estado reacio a tomar
una decisión tan drástica como suspender
las importaciones de petróleo ruso
porque es consciente de que esto
elevaría los precios de la gasolina
porque porque rusia es el principal
exportador mundial de gas y el segundo
de petróleo nada que hacer por otro lado
occidente está cerrando más el cerco
contra los oligarcas rusos cuéntenos los
hombres más ricos y poderosos de rusia
han venido siendo blanco de sanciones
por parte de occidente como una manera
de presionar al presidente vladimir
putin para que frene su acción militar
contra ucrania reino unido- que es
considerado el destino por excelencia de
los oligarcas rusos fue el primer país
en apuntar les hace casi una semana y ya
van once de ellos sancionados sin poder
entrar al país y con sus activos
congelados este jueves el turno fue para
el ex vice primer ministro de rusia igor
shuválov y el magnate de la día de las
telecomunicaciones alisher usmánov quien
también es conocido como el supuesto
testaferro de putin contra este último
así como contra siete otros
multimillonarios más y sus familiares
estados unidos también anunció castigos
y dijo que habrá más en la lista de lo
que estamos hablando aquí es de
confiscar sus activos confiscar sus
yates y dificultarles enviar a sus hijos
a colegios y universidades del occidente
estos son pasos significativos que
impactarán a las personas cercanas al
presidente putin uno de los grandes
factores es por supuesto la proximidad
al presidente putin queremos que sienta
el apretón entre frío de squeeze ángel
hay un dato adicional antes de ir con
los indicadores y es que mientras tanto
más empresas se han sumado el éxodo de
rusia en netflix h&m y ahora con son el
último lote de las grandes
multinacionales que salen de ese país y
también la desarrolladora de videojuegos
electronic arts eliminó a los equipos
rusos de juegos como fifa 22 entre otros
ahora sí indicadores de la jornada pues
walt sweater cerró a la baja con los
inversionistas muy nerviosos por el
desarrollo de esta guerra tesla y amazon
lideraron las pérdidas
el golpe fue peor en europa con las
pérdidas de alrededor del 2% por el
miedo de lo que la guerra pueda causar
sobre la economía y regáleme la xix a
pues angela es una cifra bastante
eficiente porque es el 91 por ciento del
valor en bolsa que ha perdido gazprom
esta es la empresa más grande de rusia y
desde el inicio de la guerra el 24 de
febrero ha perdido el 91 por ciento un
día antes de la invasión su acción en la
bolsa de londres costaba casi 7 dólares
obviamente por apenas 58 centavos y lo
mismo ha ocurrido con la productora de
petróleo lukoil o con sberbank cuyas
acciones se pueden comprar con apenas
monedas y el rublo ruso ya vale menos de
un centavo de dólar gracias daniela y a
nuestros televidentes se quédense con
nosotros ya volvemos con más
[Aplausos]
[Música]